- One, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, and eight
and back to the fifth.
Good, let's try it again.
From the beginning.
- My name is Davon Kibble
and I will be doing ballet
with my daughter Chloe.
- When I found out I
was going to have a girl
I was very excited.
She was my only girl.
I have three boys, so this just completed
the process for me.
- It is important for me
to be here with my daughter
so I can show her how much I love her
and that I'm always going
to be there for her,
no matter what.
Even if it's ballet dancing.
- My dad can dance.
He has some moves that are
pretty hard for me to accomplish.
- Ready, go.
(music)
- My name is La Toya Bellamy.
I am the artistic director and founder
of Dancer 4 Life, L.A. dance studio.
I've been dancing for 32 years.
I started with ballet of course.
I decided to open up a dance a studio
when I turned 15 and watching my teachers,
I was like, "Oh, I can do this."
And within six months,
I became the teacher,
the choreographer, the
director of the class.
Growing up I was like,
I want to do this myself
and my dance studio has
been open for five years.
I was blessed and now I
am growing and growing
and excited to teach my
dancers ages two and up.
- Alright, you ready to do some ballet?
- I don't know.
- You're supposed to say yes!
I've got tights on and everything.
- Okay
(laughs)
- Hi daughters and dads.
- [Dads] Hello
- [La Toya] Welcome to the first day
of daddy daughter ballet.
You guys excited?
- [Dads and Daughters] Yes!
- Awesome.
So we're going to do some pirouettes.
So you're going to look for
a diamond between your legs.
- Bend your arms. Bend them.
- [Davon] Oh, like that, okay.
- Arms are going to come up and pirouette.
Good, and stretch.
- I thought I prepared myself
and stretched a little before,
but apparently we have
to go a little deeper.
(instrumental music)
- Daughters take your right
leg, put it on top of the bar.
Dads can go right behind them please.
- [Dad] Oh, okay.
- Let's try it, there you go.
- Oh, shucks.
- [La Toya] Good, now John behind Allie.
- Alright.
(girl squeals)
- [La Toya] Awesome.
Are your feet pointed?
There you go. Very good.
All the way over.
Good. Good. Stretch it out.
Feel that stretch.
- Over here. Over here.
(instrumental music)
- [La Toya] There we go.
- Point.
- I got it?
- I was just making sure the teacher
went easy on us first-timers here.
- Alright, we're going to have
a seat in butterfly position.
Please have a seat.
- What is "butterfly position"?
- Put your feet together.
- Oh, okay.
- Feet together.
- So daughters, help your dads out.
Make sure their feet are
in the correct position.
- [Melia] There we go.
- Okay.
- [Melia] You just hold it right here.
- Alright.
- Like this?
- Yes, go up and down.
- Up and down?
- [La Toya] Up and down, yes.
You're correct.
Legs up and down. Awesome.
Now stretch all the way
over into your butterfly,
head down to your toes.
- Oh
(Chloe laughs)
- That's as far as I go, Miss L.
- So you want to come
up on your left feet.
Make sure one hand is on
each side of that leg.
- I should have did a few
extra stretches myself.
I needed help with that left leg.
(dads laugh)
- Told you.
- Look, told you (laughs)
- [La Toya] And slide as far as we can.
- Stretching all the way.
- That's it, that's it (laughs).
- [Chloe] Daddy, go back further.
- I can't.
- [La Toya] Yeah, dad.
- Good job daddy.
- Point your toes.
- No.
- I feel I did pretty okay.
I have a new respect for all dancers.
- [La Toya] Alright guys,
ready. We're going to go across.
We're going to do some jetés.
- [Dad] Jeté?
- Yes, we're going to
start with the sashay.
So, right leg and you're
going to step together,
and then step and then jump.
- [Davon] Step
- [La Toya] Jump
- [Devon] Jump
Good, arabesque.
- Little bit uncomfortable.
Something felt a bit weird.
- [La Toya] Jump. Jeté.
Good, arabesque.
- I think the jetés were a
little difficult to begin with.
- [La Toya] And, sashay.
And jeté....jeté...jeté.
Good, arabesque.
- My favorite part was
when we did choreography.
- Alright, girls, dads,
you ready for some choreo?
- [Dads and daughters] Yes!
- Alright.
- [Girl] I really liked
when my dad picked me up.
[Dad] Was glad that I was able to catch on
to the choreography.
- [John] Standing on my
toes is difficult (laughs)
- Wooo
(dads and daughters laugh)
- You gotta go there.
- [Melia] I'm too tall.
- You guys ready to perform it?
- [Dads And Daughters] Yes!
- Yes, alright. Let's do this!
(instrumental classical music)
- How did I do Ari?
- Great!
I think my dad did really great.
- I did my dad did amazing.
- I think my dad did outstanding.
- You know what, I enjoyed it.
I'm just glad that I was able
to catch on to the choreography.
- I would say to all the
dads out there, get involved.
Enjoy your daughters as
much as you possibly can
while they're little girls.